This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Hover, get 10% off your next domain
purchase using the code real engineering.
In 2007, Steve Jobs introduced the original
iPhone.
One of the most innovative and revolutionary
products of the 21st century, ushering a new
era of smartphones, and waiting in line to
get one.
The furore for this new phone was due, in
large part, to the LCD multi-touch panel that
allowed you to see and interact with the device
with a clarity and mobility never seen before.
Apple wasn’t the first to introduce touch
panel LCDs into cell phones, but they were
first to make people care about it, they revolutionised
what was once a clunky and frustrating technology,
to one that could be used easily for typing
on screen and gesture control.
The screen itself featured a 3.5” diagonal
320x480 resolution LCD.
Most major shifts in iPhone usability and
design over the years have been around the
display, from the iPhone to the iPhone 3GS
the phones had a display density of 163 pixels
per inch.
The iPhone 4 “retina” display doubled
that to 326 PPI, halving the size each pixel.
This pixel size remained constant for another
7 years, while generational progress was made
in LCD technology.
More consistent backlighting, consistent colour
and brightness when viewing off angle, and
a wider colour gamut gave the new iPhone 8
the gold standard LCD panel.
But for the iPhone X, Apple is taking a sudden
departure from its faithful LCD screens, and
jumping in bed with their arch-rival, Samsung,
who are manufacturing it’s new OLED display.
The Apple watch used OLED, but Samsung has
been utilizing and maturing OLED technology
for years in their Galaxy smartphones.
This is the first time most Apple enthusiasts
will experience OLED technology.
So, what are the fundamental differences between
LCD and OLED?
LCD stands for liquid crystal display.
The liquid crystals used, fall somewhere in
between a liquid and a solid, which allows
them to change their molecular orientation
when an electrical current is applied.
This is incredibly useful,as it allows us
to use the molecules to manipulate light that
is passing through the liquid crystal.
Liquid crystal pixels do not produce their
own light, and so require a backlight to provide
the displays lighting.
In the past, cold cathode fluorescent lamps
(CCLF) were used, but in modern LCD panels
LED backlighting is used with a backlight
uniformity filter added to ensure even lighting
across the panel.
Next the light passes through a polarization
film which only lets light traveling in the
horizontal orientation to pass through, followed
by the liquid crystal group and then another
polarizing filter oriented 90 degrees to the
first.
If you are familiar with polarizing filters,
you will know that light cannot pass through
two filters when they are aligned perpendicular
to each other.
So, light depends on this liquid crystal layer
to orientate the light to allow it to pass
through the second filter.
The liquid crystal layer is sandwiched between
two electrodes and two pieces of etched glass,
forcing the liquid crystal molecules into
a near predictable 90 degree twist.
When a voltage is applied through the electrodes,
the crystal molecules begin to realign in
the direction of the current, a larger voltage
will result in full 90 degree twist.
As light passes through, it will follow the
direction of the crystal molecules before
encountering the second polarization filter.
So the liquid crystal layer essentially acts
as a controllable light valve.
If light is allowed to pass it will travel
through a coloured filter, giving it one of
three colours.
Red, blue or green.
This structure is called a subpixel.
Combine three sub-pixels with red green and
blue filters and you have a single traditional
RGB liquid crystal pixel.
This brings up a few really interesting characteristics
of LCDs.
The first is that even when the panel is displaying
a black image, the backlight is always on,
causing a large battery drain and some light
leakage at pixel boundaries and the edges
of the screen, which negatively affects the
screen contrast ratio.
With the iPhone X, Apple engineers have adopted
a fundamentally new display technology, OLED
or organic light emitting diodes.
Samsung have a near perfect monopoly on the
manufacturing market for these screens, manufacturing
90% of the world’s supply and holding the
majority of the world’s patents [1].
Forcing competitors like Apple, to purchase
from them to remain up to date with the best
technology on the market, although it hasn't
stopped them from reportedly investing billions
in Samsung's major competitor, LG Display
[2].
OLED works very differently than LCD in a
few key ways.
For starters, there is no backlight.
Instead, each pixel is self illuminating through
the light emitting process called electrophosphorescence.
There are two organic compounds called the
emissive and conductive layers that are sandwiched
between an anode and a cathode.
As an electrical current flows from the cathode
to the anode, electrons are given to the emissive
layer, and removed from the conductive layer.
The electrons in the emissive layer now migrate
to fill the holes in the conductive layer.
When they do, extra energy is released as
a photon.
This entire process is controlled and structured
by the TFT matrix, and the structure is placed
on a substrate of either glass or polymer.
Since there is no backlight and each individual
pixel is individually controlled, substantial
power saving can occur when displaying dark
or black images.
In addition, OLED panels are significantly
thinner and lighter than their LCD counterparts,
allowing for slimmer devices with razor sharp
bezels and flexible screens, like the one
in the Samsung Galaxy S8.
Lastly, OLED panels have high brightness and
true zero pixel values, leading to insane
contrast ratios of over 1,000,000:1.
Blacks are inky, colors are more vibrant,
and localized brightness can be greatly improved.
There are some growing pains with OLED technology
holding it back in the mainstream consumer
market.
The chief limiting factor is burn in.
Burn in occurs when the organic layers of
the pixel begin to breakdown from prolonged
usage.
As the layers decay, they can become significantly
less bright than the pixels around them, which
can make stationary UI elements appear as
a ghost image.
This mainly occurs from prolonged static images,
such as user interface icons and is the single
largest reasons OLED computer monitors or
TVs are not yet mainstream.
Not to mention the cost, which can be 1.5
to 2 times higher than an equivalent LCD panel.
OLED has fundamental strengths over LCD that
will open up the possibilities for how and
where displays are used in the world around
us.
LG Display has a consumer OLED television
that is only 2.57mm thick, they are working
on transparent OLEDs that can integrated into
glass panels, and various OLED manufacturers
are working towards foldable displays.
With continued improvement OLED displays look
set to revolutionise the way we consume and
view information in the world around us.
Websites on your phone will look better than
ever, but what’s a good website without
a great domain name.
Hover is the easiest and best place to register
a custom domain or email.
You can even purchase domains right from your
iPhone using Apple Pay.
They have over 400 domain extensions, and
the best customer service in the business.
Seriously, they’ve won awards.
I couldn’t believe my luck when I saw that
the real.engineering domain was available
on Hover and purchased it immediately and
it took less than 20 seconds to make it mine.
I now have a custom email address that couldn’t
suit my channel better.
If you are looking for a unique domain name,
Hover is the best place to get one and you
can get 10% off your next purchase using the
code RealEngineering.
You could get the real.investment domain to
use for online investment training site, or
you want the real.security domain name for
your cyber security blog.
Whatever domain you want, you will probably
be able find one that suits your needs at
Hover and you once again you can get 10% off
your next purchase using the code RealEngineering.
As always, thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters.
If you would like to see more from me the
links for my social media accounts are in
the description.